one more spectrum male we could have
firefight parker yeah i love firefight
parker i mean she just
i i she hasn't been you know posting as
much as she
as she normally does like
she uh she hasn't been doing her dance
videos which is what my favorite thing
but i will say this i respect your game
and here's why
hey guys it's me foxy parker
the reason why you're not seeing me
right now
and because and the reason i got my
hands in the air is because i'm gonna be
doing a little muffin show
so uh this is what kind of crazy person
has a does a puppet show
i mean seriously who does that and
they're going to be doing
what a lunatic of the yogi
bear sentence parody this is ridiculous
but instead of yogi and booboo and
random
[Music]
chocolate looks like a beautiful day to
some some pink biscuits
christmas sherry beauty is not good like
that i mean come up with your own stuff
at least come on
sure everybody after all i'm smarter
than the average bear
well hello there
crazy all right i'm not gonna lie this
isn't bad well i'm afraid i'm gonna have
to access your hair and i'm like
[Music]
christmas not very nice to mo show
everybody
you want some of this oh no they're
gonna fight
have a wonderful day or one more night
wherever you are in the world
show your head come on parker i want to
see you here
and what's the point of this if i can't
see you
oh my god
oh my god firefly parker
and i have a special guest
me today poppy dog jonas oh
that is a cute dog that is a cute dog
oh that's a cute dog anyways guys
um today i'm going to be doing
a
a blues buffalo commercial that is a
rhythm assistant for my dog
showing us where did that career assist
me what a cute dog
yeah so here we go they say i love my
dog
oh you should
i've been giving my dog dog food
like um she's doing a commercial
benefall
because libraries canine but none of
those
seemed to have worked
so um i decided
that since his family i'm going to feed
him like
family i'm going to feed him healthy
foods
just like i be myself healthy foods
jonathan's family soy freedom blue
thank you for watching and i'll see you
tomorrow no no problem firefly look at
that dog
look at that dog oh look at him look at
that puppy
i love firefly i love firefly
you kidding me how can you not